hello and welcome to datatab
we have started to implement a new
feature in datatab
and now i would like to explain it to
you and i would be very happy if you can
give me some feedback
what problem do we solve with this
feature it is very complicated
especially at the beginning to
understand the difference
between directed and undirected
hypotheses
and especially to calculate them
correctly
to solve this problem we have started to
add a new feature to data tab
with this feature you can easily
calculate directed hypotheses
we started with the t-test for
independent samples
but if you like it we can expand it to
other methods as well
and now i will show you how it works
let's say you want to test the directed
hypothesis
that men earn more than women and you
conducted a survey
in order to find it out i simply use
this sample data now
i know it's much too small but it's just
an example
of course you can use your own data as
well by clicking
clear table now you want to analyze the
variable
salary and gender so you just click on
salary and gender and here is the new
feature of data tab
datatab will formulate the null and
alternative hypothesis
for you so the null hypothesis is
gender has no influence on salary
and the alternative hypothesis would be
gender
has an influence on salary and further
datadeb correctly calculates the p-value
for you
depending on whether you have a directed
or an
undirected hypothesis therefore you can
now choose
whether your hypothesis is directed or
if it's undirected if you select
directed you will be asked whether the
salary of
man or women should be higher in the
alternative hypothesis
in our example we want to check whether
the salary of
man is higher afterwards you will see
the newly formulated hypotheses
first the null hypothesis which says
that the male group has a smaller or
equal salary compared to the female
group
and second the alternative hypothesis
which says that the male group
has a larger salary than the female
group
the calculated p-value is now
automatically adjusted to this case
and you can easily read the p-value in
this table
additionally you can also look at the
summary in words
the null hypothesis that the mail group
has a smaller or equal value of the
variable salary
compared to the female group was tested
using a one-tailed t-test for
independent samples
assuming equal variances the result was
statistically significant
so the null hypothesis is thus rejected
if we now turn the whole thing around
and check whether women have a higher
income
we certainly get a non-significant
result for this question
what do you think about this new feature
is it useful for you
currently this feature is only available
for the t-test for independent samples
what should be our next step maybe edit
to
correlation analysis i'm happy about
your feedback
thanks for watching and have a nice day